BUT LET'S GET INTO IT, THE FIRST
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY
DEBATE WAS LAST NIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS, YOU
GUY, THE QUEST TO DE-NEGROFY THE
WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES.
(LAUGHTER)
OKAY SO LAST NIGHT'S DEBATE OR
AS I LIKE TO CALL IT THE SEARCH
FOR HILLARY'S RUNNING MATE,
OKAY, IT WAS INTERESTING THAT
CNN WAS TREATING IT MORE LIKE IT
WAS MAYWEATHER VERSUS PACQUIAO.
>> IN THE HEART OF LAS VEGAS A
CAMPAIGN OF HEAD-TO-HEAD
RIVALS THAT HAVE NEVER GONE
HEAD-TO-HEAD BEFORE.  HILLARY
CLINTON, THE FRONTRUNNER,
BERNIE SANDERS THE SURPRISE
THREAT, THREE OTHER POLITICAL
VETERANS ARE IN THE MIX.
THREE OTHER POLITICAL
VETERANS.
IN THE MIX?
YOU COULDN'T EVEN SAY THEIR
NAMES, CNN?
[BLEEP] ACTUALLY, TO BE FAIR,
NOBODY CAN REMEMBER THEIR NAMES.
SERIOUSLY, I INTERVIEWED ONE OF
THOSE GUYS.
I CAN'T REMEMBER HIS NAME.
AND DAN-- WAS IT DAN, LINCOLN
CHAFEE, YEAH, NOW LINCOLN IS A
REALLY NICE PERSON, ALL RIGHT.
I DON'T WANT TO MAKE FUN OF HIM.
BUT COME ON GUYS, HE'S MAKING IT
WAY TOO EASY WITH THAT OVERSIZED
SUIT.
OR THE TIE HE CLEARLY CUT OUT OF
HIS MOTEL CURTAINS THE HOUR
BEFORE THE DEBATE, SURELY, I'M
JUST SAYING.
I DON'T-- I DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT.
AND THAT WAS THE SMALL TRAIN
WRECK.
THE BIG TRAIN WRECK CAME WHEN HE
STARTED TALKING.
>> MY FIRST VOTE, I JUST
ARRIVED, MY DAD HAD DIED.
MY DAD HAD DIED.
>> IT WAS THE FIRST VOTE, MAYOR
OF MY CITY, MY DAD HAD DIED
REALLY, TRYING TO CAPTURE THE
YOUTH WITH THAT ONE. NOTHING
GETS PEOPLE TO THE POLLS LIKE
THE GRIM SPECTER OF DAD DEATH.
LINCOLN, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO WIN
THIS, MOVE ON TO JIM WEBB.
OKAY.
GUYS, I DO NOT LIKE TO FOCUS ON
PEOPLE'S LOOKS BUT I JUST CAN'T
GET PAST THE FACT THAT HE LOOKS
LIKE A MIDDLE TOE, HE DOES, I
CAN'T.
IT'S IN MY MIND.
I CAN'T GET THAT OUT OF MY HEAD.
I CAN'T.
AND NOW YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET IT OUT OF YOUR HEAD.
I'M SORRY, JIM WEBB, MIDDLE TOE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT IS
WEIRD, I WILL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE.  THE CANDIDATES WERE
GIVEN THE QUESTION BLACK LIVES
MATTER OR ALL LIVES MATTER.
NOW WE'RE AT THE DEMOCRATIC
DEBATE.
BLACK LIVES MATTER, MOVE ON,
RIGHT.
BUT I THINK JIM GOT CAUGHT IN
HIS OWN WEB.
>> EVERY LIFE IN THIS COUNTRY
MATTERS.
I HAVE HAD A LONG HISTORY OF
WORKING WITH THE SITUATION OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
SITUATION?OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
OR MAYBE THAT'S WHAT YOU CALL A
GROUP OF US?
LIKE A SCHOOL OF FISH, OR YOU
KNOW, GAGGLE OF GEESE, YOU KNOW,
IT'S A SITUATION OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THE SAME-- IT MAKES SENSE.
A SITUATION.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, THAT WOULD EXPLAIN WHY
EVERY TIME COPS SEE A GROUP OF
BLACK PEOPLE THEY GO LIEUTENANT,
WE'VE GOT A SITUATION ON OUR
HANDS.
IT MAKES SENSE IT DOES MAKE
SENSE, IT DOES MAKE SENSE.
OKAY, ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
WHAT ABOUT MARTIN O'MALLEY.
>> WHAT YOU HEARD INSTEAD ON
THIS STAGE TONIGHT WAS AN HONEST
SEARCH FOR THE ANSWERS THAT WILL
MOVE OUR COUNTRY FORWARD.
Larry: OKAY.TOTAL DREAM BOAT.
I ONLY WISH BERNIE SANDERS
IDEAS WERE COMING FROM THAT FACE
HAVE YOU SEEN HIM AT
THE BEACH?
I'M GOING TO-- I'M GOING TO CALL
HIM SECOND AMENDMENT BECAUSE
HE'S GOT THE RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS.
(APPLAUSE).
OVERALL,THE DEBATE FOR PRESIDENT
IS REALLY BETWEEN HILLARY AND
BERNIE, RIGHT, WHICH CULMINATED
IN THIS EPIC MOMENT.
>> I THINK THE SECRETARY IS
RIGHT.
AND THAT IS THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE SICK AND TIRED OF
HEARING ABOUT YOUR DAMN
E-MAILS.
NOTE TO SELF: NEVER LOSE MY
FRISBEE IN THAT OLD MAN'S
BACKYARD.
BUT WHAT A GALLANT MOVE THAT
WAS.  I GIVE BERNIE A LOT OF
CREDIT.
HE IS DEFENDING THE LADY'S HONOR
AT HIS POSSIBLE POLITICAL
EXPENSE.
THAT IS SOME SWEET ASS FROM
MAPLE SYRUP SOCIALIZING
SOCIALISM RIGHT THERE
SO HOW DID HILLARY REACT TO THAT
ONE?
(APPLAUSE).
WOW. I MEAN WHAT AN ADULT
RESPONSE.
TWO PEOPLE WHO ARE IN AN INTENSE
COMPETITION FOR THE MOST
POWERFUL JOB IN THE WORLD BUT
TREATING EACH OTHER LIKE
REASONABLE HUMAN BEINGS.
HMMMM.
BUT NICE, MOMENTS LIKE THAT,
THEY DON'T STACK UPRATINGS WISE.
THIS DEBATE WAS DOWN 42%
COMPARED TO THE LAST REPUBLICAN
DEBATE. I GUESS PEOPLE PREFER
THEIR
DEBATE HAND INTERACTIONS TO BE A
BIT MORE SPAZZY
I COULD WATCH THAT [BLEEP] ALL
DAY, GUYS.
BUT YOU KNOW, I GET IT,   LAST
NIGHT'S DEBATE WAS TOO
FRIENDLY AND FRIENDLY EQUALS
BORING.
NOW TO BE HONEST, THAT MADE ME
LONG FOR SOME OF THIS.
>> WATCH A FULLY-FORMED FETUS
ON THE TABLE
>> RIP UP THEIR BODY PARTS AND
SELL THEM LIKE THEY ARE PARTS TO
A BUICK.
>> WE HAVE TO KEEP IT ALIVE TO
HARVEST ITS BRAIN.
>> IF YOU WANT TO GIVE HIM A BIG
HUG AGAIN, GO RIGHT AHEAD.
>> RAND PAUL SHOULDN'T EVEN BE
ON THIS STAGE.
>> HARVEST ITS BRAIN.
>> YOU INTERRUPTED EVERYBODY
ELSE, YOU CAN'T INTERRUPT ME.
>> HARVEST ITS BRAIN.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE).
NOW I'M NOT SAYING THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE BETTER IDEAS.
I'M JUST SAYING THEY HAVE HAVE
BETTER INSULTS.
AND BRAIN HARVESTING TALK ALWAYS
MAKES BETTER TELEVISION, YOU
GUYS.
NOW A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK CARLY
BABY BRAIN HARVESTING FIORINA
WON THAT DEBATE AND PEOPLE SAY
HILLARY WON THIS DEBATE.
SO GO ON, LADIES, GO ON!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
BUT AND IT'S FUNNY THAT THE
KNOCK AGAINST HILLARY IS THAT
SHE'S TOO SMART, RIGHT.
SHE'S TOO COMPETENT, YOU KNOW.
SHE'S UNRELATABLE.
SHE NEEDS TO BE MORE HUMAN.
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, CAN SHE ACCOMPLISH THIS.
WELL, FOR ME, THERE IS ONE
MOMENT THAT TOTALLY HUMANIZED
HER.
>> ALL THE CANDIDATES ARE BACK.
WHICH I'M VERY HAPPY TO SEE.
A LONG STORY.
LET'S CONTINUE, WE.
SECRETARY CLINTON, WELCOME BACK.
>> THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, IT DOES TAKE ME A
LITTLE LONGER, THAT'S ALL I CAN
SAY.
!HILLARY PEES? OH MY GOD, SHE'S
JUST LIKE ME!
I'M VOTING FOR HER.
I DIDN'T KNOW SHE PEED.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO.
MAYBE ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING
MOMENTS CAME DURING A COMMERCIAL
BREAK.
>> IF YOU LOVE SHRIMP LIKE I
LOVE SHRIMP COME TO RED LOBSTER.
>> FOR AS MUCH SHRIMP AS MUCH AS
YOU WANT IT.
THAT'S RIGHT, BITCHES!
IT'S ENDLESS SHRIMP SEASON.
WHAT OTHER AWESOME ADS RAN
DURING THE DEBATE.
>> DEAR HILLARY CLINTON YOU
IGNORED CALLS FOR
HELP IN BENGHAZI, 4 AMERICANS
WERE MURDERED.
YOU LIED.
WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE
COME ON, RIGHTWING AD PEOPLE,
CAN'T A BROTHER ENJOY ENDLESS
SHRIMP?
ALL RIGHT, LINCOLN CHAFFEE CHEER
ME UP.
>> MY DAD HAD DIED.
Larry: OKAY.ALL RIGHT.
SO IN THE ENDS, WAS THE DEBATE
BORING? YEAH. DID IT HAVE ALL
THE FIREWORKS AND TALK ABOUT
DEAD BABY PARTS AND OVERT RACISM
AND FULL-BLOWN HOMOPHOBIA OF THE
OTHER DEBATE?
>> NO. DID I SIMULTANEOUSLY
WATCH THE DODGERS GAME, YES,
YES, I ACTUALLY DID.
THAT'S A REAL PHOTO.
BUT THE POINT IS WE HAVE THESE
DEBATES TO DETERMINE WHO IS THE
BEST PERSON TO LEAD THE FREE
WORLD.
NOT TO FIND THE BEST ENTERTAINER
IN CHIEF.
BECAUSE, BECAUSE IF THAT WERE
THE CASE, I WOULD VOTE FOR
CEDRIC THE.